here with reaction the author of the
best-selling book firebrand
florida congressman matt gates and ohio
congressman jim jordan big moments for
both of you today
all right jim jordan i'll take debate
who is next who's next
well it's actually it could be anyone
and americans don't want to live in fear
sean because we have this thing called
the constitution the bill of rights and
the first amendment
but i said three weeks on the house
floor three weeks ago on the house floor
during the impeachment debate
i said don't think i spoke to the
democrats i said don't think the
canceled culture won't come after you
too
sean it took all of 13 days for that
statement to be proven true because what
happened last week
in san francisco the school board said
the dianne feinstein elementary school
will no longer be named after senator
feinstein
so even a liberal icon in the state of
california who is represented at state
in the united states senate for decades
even even she's not woke enough and she
gets cancelled
for something she said 37 years ago
that is how dangerous this is the
democrats are playing with fire
and that was going to stand up and talk
about what the canceled culture mob
is doing how they're attacking our first
amendment liberties and make sure
that we push back on this and it stops
happening because it should not take
place
in this great country and you know i
watched closely your the hearing with
nadler today
matt gates and what does it take all of
10 15 seconds to say the pledge of
allegiance and
uh that i guess is unacceptable to
congressman nadler
jerry nadler gave us the i gave it the
office
version of patriotism today jim jordan
and i are speaking to you from
a capital city that is draped in barbed
wire that is crisscrossed in barricades
and inside the capitol building a woman
who got over 75 percent of the vote in
her district
was was denied her opportunity of full
service because
democrats believe that the people inside
of washington dc
here for this occupation know better
than the people throughout this great
country
it's a travesty i'm glad that jim and i
are you know here fighting to ensure
that there is that opportunity to
have people who disagree on substance
without trying to
totally cancel one another i think it's
also interesting that as they were
objecting to
the pledge of allegiance the reasoning
was
rather tortured democrat congresswoman
corey bush
said that the pledge of allegiance was a
symbol of white supremacy
and that to accept a statement of the
pledge of allegiance would just
reinforce
racism in our country and i thought gosh
at a time when there seems to be such a
search for unity
we could do a lot better than this type
of divisive rhetoric
emerging from house democrats you know
jim jordan
nobody could defend the comments about
the plane hitting the pentagon
or the school shootings didn't happen or
all the other things that we talked
about last night
i have no idea what caused her to think
those things
she says she doesn't believe them any
longer i've never heard a democrat or
anybody in the media mob
ever apologize not one time for the lies
they told
america uh and what they did to this
country dragging this country through
their entire conspiracy theory over
three long years all of it
got debunked nobody said a thing
yeah no i mean james clapper said
publicly that oh there was this
collusion but what did he say behind
closed doors when he was under oath in
front of the intelligence committee he
said there was no evidence
of any type of collusion between the
trump campaign and russia to meddle with
the election
so it was a fraud from the get-go and
yet they pushed that conspiracy
theory so much guess what on january 6
2017
when it came time to count the electors
for president trump's victory
the democrat chair of the rules
committee sean objected to alabama
the same guy who started the debate
today's debate off went after marjorie
taylor greene
that individual who started the day
going after her that individual
was four years ago the one who said we
can't accept the electors from alabama
based on that conspiracy theory so talk
about a double standard i mean alabama
president trump won alabama by 30 points
so he tried to
overturn the will of the people in that
state based on a conspiracy theory
but today they take marjorie taylor
green's committee's
assignments from her and as matt just
said she can't represent the people in
her district like she's supposed to
this is ridiculous you know if matt
gates the firebrand if he had to start
with apologies
jim jordan i don't think there's enough
hours in any one broadcast state
to ever possibly go through the entire
list of the fire brand
he was great in committee today listen
we all need more grace
sean amen
uh we only kid you because you are a bit
of a firebrand we like it
it's an appropriate title for your
best-selling book um all right that'd be
a good show one day you can host it
fire brand with matt gates what do you
think
all right thank you bob jim jordan would
be my first guest all right there you go
well not me
great i'm low on the list